so one of the things you talked about in
your presidential campaign and also talk
about in the book is the sort of
corruption of money in politics both
when you're
running for office and you're having to
solicit all these donations then you get
into office and the first thing you got
to do is dial for dollars again and go
meet with lobbyists and raise money from
lobbyists and that whole cycle not to
mention
um and we see this i would say with
kirsten cinema right now you know
pushing back against the reconciliation
bill at the same time that she's running
raising money from the very corporate
interest that would benefit from that
bill being killed at the same time
you're looking towards okay when i get
out of congress then i'm going to get a
cushy gig in the private sector for x
and y and z company so let me make sure
i'm happy with them they're happy with
me
while i'm here in the people's house so
you talk about
that rot and that corruption
and how corrosive it is to and how it
messes up the incentives of
people who may be genuinely good people
who want to serve and end up not doing
what they set out to do once they get to
washington
um how will you protect the forward
party to make sure that it's not subject
to that same sort of corrosive impact of
money in politics
you know i got asked this the other day
crystal and my immediate response was
who on earth would donate to the forward
party
uh because we don't run anything you
know
like if you're a big corporate it's like
let me get behind the forward party
because they're really gonna lower my
taxes you know the only people who would
donate to ford are people that want to
see our democracy actually live up to
that name
uh that they want a system that will
have our legislators answered a majority
of us instead of uh the most ideological
minority um now if we're running the the
show uh then i would love to have
another conversation with you about how
we're going to make sure that the the
forward party doesn't get overrun by
corporate donors because uh we're
looking at you know
innovative ways to do that um
but right now i mean it really is sort
of funny in the sense that and like no
one rational would donate
to the board party for
uh for self-serving reasons because it
just wouldn't make any sense
i think you saw yourself a little short
there though because you know you're a
very influential person and you have a
big following so
it's not crazy to me to imagine that
there would be people or interests who
would love to have access to that i mean
first for some of these people like to
throw you a hundred thousand dollars or
whatever it's nothing to them why not
place a bet on this thing even if it is
a long shot chance
well if they do that and and uh it pays
off then you know we'd be happy to
publicly disclose all the people that
have donated to us and then we can have
a conversation as to what the future
holds
um but i would have to say it would take
a real
uh visionary with a very long time
horizon to do it for bad reasons
[Laughter]
maybe you're maybe i am selling myself
short crystal maybe i'm cool enough
where people just throw money at it to
hang out with me um
everybody's cool enough to be subject to
these influence i mean as you point out
a lot of this isn't about sometimes in
the commentary it can get very much
caught up on individual personalities
and like this person is sold out and
that person is corrupt and people have
agency and they deserve blame for those
things but we're all human and like
we're all subject to these sort of
corrosive influences i see it in my own
work you know one of the things that we
tried to do with our business model is
protect ourselves from being
too driven by the youtube algorithm or
by what's going to be monetized or not
by youtube because look i know i'm a
human being i know when i was at msnbc
and they told me hey next time you say
something mean about hillary clinton you
got to run it bias i know that impacted
the way that i covered her so
i just i have a lot of humility i know
you do too about how we're all subject
to these influences even when we have
the best of intentions
i'm with you for sure and i think that's
the big lesson about our current system
crystal it's one reason why again we're
all pulling our hair out wondering why
it's not getting any better the system
is fundamentally corruptive
and then what we're doing is we're
pretending that certain people are good
and not cropped and though those people
are corrupt and then someone's like oh
that person's a hypocrite that the
system is dirty the system is making it
so that reasonable person can enter and
then try their best out try their heart
out but they'll be there grinding and
dialing for dollars someone that gives
to them is going to represent some
corporate interest you know like that
that's the way our system is designed
and that the best thing we can do right
now is to try and clean up our system so
that it actually is more responsive to
popular will
and this is the best way to do so
so i'm with you 100
i think it was a quote from ezra klein
in his book that i quote in in my book
that uh
corruptive systems overcome good
individuals with ease
and and that's what we're seeing over
and over again and we're wondering why
it's now working
so i wanted to ask you a little bit more
about some of the planks because i i
think they're really interesting and um
you you mentioned how grace intolerance
is one of the ones that you find to be
sort of most critical and most vital
that's something that really resonates
with me because i do think we
um
we have a situation right now where
people feel very impotent they feel like
uh they did the thing they were supposed
to do they voted for the right candidate
so they got out there and organized or
they gave their 10 bucks or whatever
and they're still not able to see that
change in that progress that they've
been wanting to now for years and years
and so i think a lot of people not a lot
of people but some people turn that
sense of impotence and the way that they
can find power is by well let me judge
this person let me shame this person let
me call this person out let me be full
of condemnation
rather than hey how do we build
solidarity how do we build a cohesive
movement that can actually effectuate
change so
talk to me a little bit about when i see
grace intolerance that's what i think
about but talk to me about what you
think about when you put those two words
into your um party platform
well one thing i think about are my
family members who voted for trump uh
and i still love them and hold them dear
even though they voted for trump
uh
to your point there's so much pain and
suffering and rage and it's manifesting
in different ways in different quarters
it's legitimate it's real
one of the things i want to do is try
and channel all of that energy into
something that's productive and
solutions oriented that's what the
forward party hopes to do
but the grace intolerance i was thinking
about really is just to try to embrace
our shared humanity and our fall ability
and that that and our difference uh one
of the points i make in the book
um is that a lot of people's politics
are born of circumstances they did not
have any control over
and so then
despising them for that
is
not
one it's not helpful but it's also not
acknowledging their
their humanity in the same way i mean i
grew up with people of uh who were
uh
i grew up with a lot of italian
americans in upstate new york
and
uh you know i got um
picked on a fair amount as one of the
lone asian kids in my school
um and
no like looking at those people now i
mean i haven't seen them all uh and
whatnot i mean like we
were probably in very different places
politically but
you know like you you still
shared so much uh time and experiences
with them and uh it's
it's something that's gotten lost now
the ideological barriers particularly in
a two-party system where it becomes good
versus evil on both sides um
then
we're never going to get anywhere and
we're going to end up ginning up the
engines of personal destruction
we're just going to keep on having this
rise and fall
of just about everyone who raises their
hand and tries to do something positive
and then
the people that are going to to end up
riding various waves are going to be not
the people you want
so that way like if they're just
waves of negative emotion then the
people that will harness those waves are
going to be not super
uh productive uh individuals
so it's hopefully an antidote to that
hopefully saying look
i disagree with you on a lot of things
but you're still a human being uh you
know like i screw up i'm still a human
being i try and put in the book
various episodes of my screwing up as a
parent or a partner or friend or a boss
or a candidate or whatever it is
um and
i know like it's you get up and do the
best you can the next day i think that
if we can
forgive
ourselves and each other then we'll have
a much better chance at getting some
positive change done than if we're
really really
intent on trying to pick people apart
and find the worst in each other yeah i
mean i 100 agree with that do you see
that as mostly like a um an ethos a sort
of moral value or do you think that
there are actual policy choices that we
could make that would help to create
that culture
biggest policy choice we could make is
open primaries and right choice voting
because then all of a sudden you'd have
really diverse points of view and no one
could bully you for wasting your vote
and you know be like people could show
up and
um and you'd have a much higher level of
dynamism and the incentives would be
towards a higher degree of
reasonableness because if you put a
reasonable legislator in there and say
hey cater to the 20
most extreme and polarized voters in
your district guess what they're going
to sound more unreasonable
so when you talk about something that'll
actually make us more reasonable you
have to set up incentives that reward
reasonableness that's what i hope the
forward party becomes we're like the
reward for reasonableness like the the
the wet blanket that will bring the
temperature down andrew yang america's
wet blanket uh you know it's like
something along those lines uh like we
just gotta
kind of get people focused on things
that are actually gonna help us is right
now and ezra klein says this it says
that right now we're we're just feeding
cycles of political rage that are
leading to madness
[Music]
you